because Joe Rogan has been waking up for
quite some time we thought we'd just go
back to this one from a couple months
ago this is Rogan getting attacked by
Jimmy Kimmel on his quote-unquote comedy
show oh no this isn't a couple months
ago this is earlier this month this is
like two weeks ago uh Rogan getting
attacked by Jimmy Kimmel just two weeks
ago over vaccines
one of the things Joe Rogan recommended
was Ivermectin here's the thing I don't
get you won't take the vaccine but you
will take Ivermectin I mean that you
know good old Ivermectin
there's a product I can try and by the
way if you're looking for advice from a
former host of The Man Show call me next
time okay because I have a
I have a second opinion on this
you know what he means by that because
the co-host of the man show was Adam
Carolla that's the one who did it with
Jimmy Kimmel and they used to have a
bunch of big boob women jumping up on
trampolines for a half hour that was the
show so I don't know what he means that
Joe Rogan was a host of that thing or
but okay let's just put that aside the
point is
Ivermectin does work you should talk to
your doctor okay fine but they it's not
that they just go after those with a
platform why are they going after Rogan
why did CNN spend those weeks going
after Rogan it was because Rogan was
bigger than CNN it wasn't because they
thought he was racist right you guys all
know that but they will also go after
you if you make a choice in your life
you know I'd prefer not to be injected
with their experimental medication
that's something that I would prefer not
to do or I certainly don't want to be
forced into it they will literally go
after you here is Kimmel in May of 21
going after those who didn't want that
mRNA jab which turns out has a lot of
problems more than 100 million adults in
the United States are now fully
vaccinated which is good but
unfortunately more than one in four say
they are not planning to get the vaccine
ever 26 percent of Americans are
planning to skip the shot altogether
which is crazy to me I get the people
skeptical of politicians or celebrities
telling them what to do but we should
listen to doctors these are men and
women who've been on the front line
lines of this thing risking their lives
to save ours and they're frustrated and
who could blame them if we don't get
more people vaccinated we could see new
mutations of this virus and go through
this all over again so as a public
service we asked some real doctors to
offer their best advice to those who are
on the fence about the vaccine and pay
attention just get the vaccine roll them
up and get the vaccine and tell your
friend on Facebook to stick to jewelry
foreign
there was more to that clip we cut it
for you because you know it's early in
the day and it's Monday and I know
you're a productive person with things
to do first off those doctors should all
be fired imagine you're a doctor you are
supposed to look at someone's chart
you're supposed to see how old they are
how healthy they are what their family
history is what they eat what they drink
etc etc and then you're supposed to make
recommendations imagine going on a TV
show to blanket tell people that they
should be injected with what we know now
is a vaccine that simply does not work
that the one of the inventors of the
very technology behind mRNA uh Dr Robert
Malone now says is causing a severe
degradation of people's immune systems
okay and it's allowing dormant viruses
to break free but imagine that you would
go on a TV show and just berate people
even in a joking fashion that they
should get vaccinated
[Music]
thank you